News. Bad.
We're bankrupt.
Oh, I borrowed money to invest in Bitcoin.
Then the price crashed and I sold at a huge
loss. We're ruined. Oh, sorry. I didn't
realize you were watching TV.
The tragic impact destroyed the planet
Klarg, along with its 50 billion inhabitants.
In other news, Morbo. Guess what's back.
The planet, Klarg?
Nope.
The price of Bitcoin.
Wha?
The virtual "money" is soaring once again,
leading to a high-tech gold rush.
Prospectors are heading west where cheap,
filthy electricity beckons the desperate.
This gives me a desperate idea!
Haven't you learned that Bitcoin is just a
pyramid scheme for rubes?
Yes, and my plan is to exploit those rubes.
You see, the new mining chips are made from
element 81, thallium, a rare element found out west.
I plan to actually mine it, then sell
it to the Bitcoin "miners".
It's a sure way to repay my loan brokers.
Oh!
Yo. We're also leg brokers.
Goodbye, Robot Mafia!